[Applause]
these past few months have been proven
to be one of the most challenging starts
to the school year for millions of
students across the country
so when i heard about this amazing
elementary school teacher going above
and beyond for his students
to help make learning a little easier
well we knew we had to meet him
here he is say hello to alejandro dias
granados
from eton elementary school
in washington d.c okay
your story is so incredible like tell us
about your school first of all yeah so
eton elementary is
a school in washington d.c it is in ward
7 northeast d.c
this community has been underserved for
several years
however this community is filled with
such cultural wealth so i like to
describe it as a culturally wealthy
community although it is a title one
school
and majority of the students are
receiving free and reduced lunch but
it is such a loving and caring community
you know down from the the parents to
the teachers the administration
everyone in that community really
pitches in to make sure that
um our students get what they need and
you know eitan is such a beacon of hope
in that community
i think right now when just all bets are
off
uh everybody is sort of
everybody is really figuring out
district by district
city by city the rules like your school
is not open right now you're still
virtual
right where my daughter's school is open
and trying it
and um i felt you know scared i was very
nervous and
you just don't know what is right and
what is wrong and
everybody has a different sort of order
and plan
and in the fact that yours is virtual
what has been your personal mission to
help the students succeed right now
yeah so my personal mission always has
been since when i
uh started at eitan is to give my
students access to a variety of people
programs resources and connections
to and really enhance their learning
experience so it's been a challenge
um you know with the pandemic starting
and teachers really trying to
do everything that they can the teachers
at our school have been amazing to
really trying to connect with students
whether it's through facetime or twitter
instagram or any sort of way that we can
connect with students
that's what we've really been trying and
you know and it's worked out pretty well
for us but you know it is a huge
challenge
do you think any of your students or the
other staff members might be watching
right now
um maybe perhaps we are closed from
school today so they could
possibly be watching i'm not sure you
know what i actually know they are
because they're right here in our
virtual audience
oh my gosh harmony jalen
aiden thank you guys so much for coming
here
like give the shout outs and support
and um i just love when we i i love that
you said the word community
because i do feel like as we're trying
to reinvent the wheel
um and i look back at pictures of 1918
and 1919 and
you know i watch a lot of pbs and like
people are doing outdoor schools they're
doing virtual schools and
some people are podding and hiring one
teacher
and and going that way some schools are
going back and
there sort of is no rules um which is a
little anarchy and scary and
intimidating and at the same time it's
an incredible opportunity to reinvent
the rules
and i just think that you and your
community are doing such a phenomenal
job because everybody's sort of tasked
to do things differently
and the way that you're doing it is so
inspiring to us